Imagine color coding your entire life, alienating your closest friends, working like 80 hour
weeks to the point of sheer exhaustion and genuinely believing that you're the only sane
person left on earth.
Or a picture standing outside a party that you desperately want to join, but your brain
is just screaming at you that the moment you walk through the door, you'll be fundamentally
humiliated.
Yeah.
Today we are looking at a really fascinating set of medical diagnostic prep notes.
They reveal why some of the most profound psychological disorders don't actually feel like disorders
at all to the people living with them.
Right.
While others feel like an inescapable prison.
Exactly.
So welcome to the deep dive.
We're really glad you're here with us today.
I mean, usually when we think about a medical diagnosis, there's this expectation of mechanical
precision.
Oh, absolutely.
Like you break your arm, the x-ray shows that jagged white line, and the doctor just
points and says, yep, there it is.
Right.
It's visible.
It's totally categorized.
This material we have today, these clinical study notes that are actually designed for
doctors preparing for the medical exams, it kind of drags us completely out of that comforting
binary world.
Yeah.
It really does.
We are wading into the human mind, specifically a category called cluster C personality disorders.
And these are the anxious and fearful personalities.
Which is such an intense category to dive into.
It is.
And I know what you listening to this might be thinking, right?
Clinical definitions and exam preps sound like incredibly dry textbook material.
Oh, well, the clinical jargon certainly tries its best to make it sound dry.
Yeah.
But honestly, beneath all that terminology, these notes are actually a raw map of human
survival strategy.
Wow.
Yeah, that's a great way to put it.
The whole foundation of this entire cluster C category is anxiety.
I mean, it is just pure fear.
But the way that fear dictates a person's reality is entirely different in each disorder
we're going to explore.
Right.
What makes these prep what's so fascinating is their heavy focus on diagnostic traps.
Yes.
I love how the author refers to them as traps.
It makes the whole diagnostic process sound like navigating a minefield or something.
Well, that's a very accurate way for a clinician to view it, honestly, because these conditions
mimic other very similar sounding issues.
Right.
They look alike on the surface.
Exactly.
So if a doctor only looks at the surface behavior, like just the symptom, without
digging into the underlying psychological mechanism of why the behavior is happening,
they will fall right into the trap.
And completely misdiagnose the patient.
Yep.
100%.
Okay.
Let's unpack this with the first personality type in the notes.
We're starting with a really profound fear of social interaction, which is avoidant personality
disorder.
Code F60.6 for the exam takers out there.
Right.
Avoidant.
The core symptoms listed here are pervasive social inhibition, deeply rooted feelings
of inadequacy, and this massive hypersensitivity to negative evaluation.
It's all consuming for them.
Right.
The notes describe a person who actively avoids social and work situations that involve interpersonal
contact.
But wait, I have to ask a question here.
If they're avoiding all social contact, how do we know they aren't just like extremely
introverted?
Yeah.
That's a really common question.
Because some people genuinely just prefer to be alone.
You know, they just don't like people.
That is the most common assumption, and it actually brings us to the core tragedy of this
specific condition.
What's fascinating here is the text emphasis on the patient's internal desire.
Okay.
The avoidant person actually longs for connection.
An extreme introvert is fully charged by being alone, right?
They find peace and solitude.
Right.
They want to be on the couch with a book.
Exactly.
But the avoidant person is drained by their loneliness.
I mean, they aren't avoiding people because they dislike them.
They're avoiding people because their brain perceives social evaluation as a literal mortal
threat.
Wow.
They're held back by this paralyzing terror of being rejected or shamed.
You know, you listening have probably felt that sting of walking into a room and feeling
like everyone is silently judging your outfit or your haircut.
Oh, sure.
Everyone knows that feeling.
Right.
Now imagine multiplying that feeling by a thousand and applying it to every single human interaction
you have every single day.
It sounds exhausting.
It's like standing outside a venue where all your peers are having a great time.
You can hear the music.
You see the lights and you want nothing more than to go inside.
Yeah.
But you are absolutely terrified of the bouncer at the door, except in this case, the bouncer
is your own internal expectation of humiliation.
That's a perfect analogy.
The desire is just burning inside them.
But the fear acts as an impenetrable concrete wall.
And this brings us directly to the first diagnostic trap the notes warn clinicians about.
Okay.
What's the trap?
The medical exam frequently tests whether a doctor can distinguish avoidant personality
disorder from a completely different category called schizoid personality disorder.
Oh, because from the outside, looking purely at the behavior, they're like identical twins,
right?
You just see two people sitting at home alone on a Friday night constantly avoiding
social gatherings.
Right.
The behavior looks identical.
Internally, however, they're operating in totally different universes.
Yeah.
As the notes put it, the avoidant person wants relationships, but fears rejection.
Okay.
The schizoid person, on the other hand, simply has no desire for relationships at all.
The drive for human connection is fundamentally just absent.
So going back to the analogy, the avoidant person is trapped outside the party weeping
because they can't bring themselves to walk in.
Yes.
But the schizoid person just walked right past the venue without breaking stride because
they genuinely do not care that a party is even happening.
Exactly.
Which completely alters the therapeutic approach.
I mean, you cannot treat a patient who desperately wants friends the same way you treat a patient
who has zero internal motivation to make them.
Right.
That makes total sense.
And this leads into the second major trap mentioned in our text, which is distinguishing
avoidant personality disorder from social anxiety disorder.
So this one seems incredibly tricky.
I mean, avoidant personality and social anxiety sound functionally the exact same.
Barely do.
If you're terrified of being judged at a work function, isn't that just social anxiety?
Well, they overlap so heavily that they frequently actually co-occur in the same
patient.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
But the prep notes highlight a mechanical differentiator.
You have to think of avoidant personality disorder as the pervasive structural version
of that fear.
Structural.
Yeah.
And that's entirely through the architecture of the person's identity.
So meaning social anxiety might be a bit more situational.
Like you're perfectly fine joking around with your family and close friends, but you
experience severe panic when you have to give a presentation at work or meet strangers.
Exactly.
But if you have avoidant personality disorder, it's just this constant inescapable lens
through which you view yourself in relation to the whole world.
Right.
It's the difference between fearing a specific social performance and holding a core
unshakable belief about your own fundamental unworthiness.
Oh, wow.
The avoidant person believes they're inherently inept, unappealing, and just
inferior to others.
That is a staggering weight to carry around every day.
But the source material does outline a path forward, thankfully.
The first line treatments listed here are cognitive behavioral therapy, CBT,
along with social skills training and gradual exposure.
Yeah. And when you understand the mechanism of the fear, those treatments make
a perfectly sense.
How so?
Well, if the brain is treating social interaction like touching a hot stove,
gradual exposure systematically forces the patient to approach social situations.
Okay.
But it starts incredibly small, like maybe just making eye contact with a cashier.
Right.
Then eventually asking a stranger for directions.
It proves to the brain's alarm system that the expected apocalyptic shame won't
actually happen, or, crucially, that if an awkward moment does happen, the
patient is totally capable of surviving it.
Yeah.
And then the CBT aspect is there to dismantle those deep-seated beliefs of
inadequacy.
They are slowly walking up to that bouncer and realizing he isn't going to
tackle them.
Exactly.
They're basically rewriting the internal code that tells them they are
inherently flawed.
So if avoidance is the extreme reaction to fearing rejection, what happens when
a mind is terrified of the exact opposite?
Right.
The other side of the coin.
It happens when the terror isn't about people getting too close, but about
people leaving.
As we move to the next section of the notes, we get a complete inversion of
the survival strategy.
We move from avoidant to dependent personality disorder.
And here, the fear of separation drives absolutely everything.
The symptoms detailed in this section describe a pervasive, excessive need to
be taken care of, and this overwhelming need is what drives incredibly
submissive and clinging behavior.
It's basically the complete outsourcing of adulthood.
The patient relies entirely on another human being to navigate the
complexities of life.
Let's anchor this in everyday reality for a second.
You listening to this have probably been in a situation where a friend simply
could not make a decision about where to eat without your input.
Right.
Which can be a little annoying.
Yeah.
Now take that paralyzing indecision and apply it to every single waking
moment.
The notes give striking examples here.
Trying to make any everyday decisions without an excessive amount of advice
and reassurance.
We aren't talking about seeking advice on buying a house.
Right.
We're talking about needing someone to validate what you're going to wear,
what you should eat for lunch, or how to phrase a casual email to a
co-worker.
Wow.
It goes way beyond just preferring companionship.
Oh, absolutely.
What you see in this disorder is a fundamental lack of self-efficacy.
It is a core driving belief that says, I am entirely incapable of surviving or
functioning without someone else piloting my life.
They don't just doubt their ability to steer the ship.
They don't even trust themselves to be a passenger on the ship without
someone holding their hand.
The text says they urgently seek a new source of support the second a
close relationship ends.
But I mean, feeling a breakup is a nearly universal human emotion.
Most people don't enjoy being single after a long relationship ends.
Sure.
So how is this different from someone who is just, you know, a serial
monogamist or hates being single?
We have to look at the survival mechanics.
To the dependent brain, submission is literally a currency used to purchase
guaranteed survival from an anchor person.
An anchor person, okay.
The brain calculates that enduring terrible situations, agreeing to
things they hate, or even tolerating outright abuse is a statistically safer bet than facing
the world alone.
Oh, wow.
People volunteer to do incredibly unpleasant things just to ensure they
remain indispensable to their caretaker.
So they become the ultimate people-cleaser out of cure terror.
Yes, exactly.
Which perfectly explains why the recommended first-line treatment is
psychotherapy aimed specifically at building autonomy.
You can't just tell this person to, you know, be more independent.
No, no.
That would be like telling someone with a broken leg to just run faster.
Yeah.
Right.
The therapist has to slowly build the internal muscle of self-trust that never
actually developed.
They have to guide the patient through making tiny decisions, experiencing the
outcome, and realizing they didn't perish in the process.
Okay.
The notes highlight another major diagnostic trap right here.
Clinicians are warned not to confuse dependent personality disorder with
borderline personality disorder.
This is a big one.
Because both of these profiles share a massive central feature, right?
Yeah.
They both harbor an intense, desperate fear of being left or abandoned.
It is a classic differential diagnosis scenario.
The core fear abandonment is identical.
But the outward manifestation, like the way the psychological immune system
reacts to that threat, is night and day.
So what does this all mean for the clinicians sitting across from the
patient?
How do they tell them apart in the room?
It comes down to observing the reaction when the threat of abandonment
is triggered.
Okay.
When a dependent person feels they're about to be left, they react by
shrinking.
They respond with submission.
They cling tighter, become more compliant, and frantically try to be
whatever the other person needs.
They basically implode.
They fold inward to make themselves easier to carry.
Yes.
Beautifully said.
But the borderline person, according to our diagnostic notes, responds
to that exact same fear of abandonment with an explosion.
Oh.
They react with immense instability, intense anger, and a chaotic
collapse of their identity.
Completely different.
Right.
And then quietly, they might lash out viciously, preemptively push
the person away so they don't have to be the one getting gummed,
or just spiral into severe emotional dysregulation.
So it's the same exact trigger, but a completely opposite reaction.
Yes.
And recognizing that distinction is vital because trying to build
basic autonomy in a dependent patient requires a vastly different
therapeutic environment than, you know, managing the volatile emotional
instability of a borderline patient.
It really highlights how creative the human mind is at inventing
survival strategies.
It really does.
So the avoidant personality seeks safety by hiding from people.
The dependent personality seeks safety by clinging to people.
But if you can't find safety by hiding, and you can't find
safety in others, where do you go?
You find safety in rules.
Yes.
You find it in systems, lists, and absolute control.
Okay.
Here's where it gets really interesting.
Enter the final disorder on our source list,
Obsessive Compulsive Personality Disorder.
Nice.
And the author of these notes actually flags this at the very
beginning of the section, calling it the single most classic
personality trap on the entire medical exam.
It is notorious, mostly because it exploits a fundamental
misunderstanding in popular culture.
Let's lay out the clinical symptoms first, just to ground it.
The defining traits of OCPD are a pervasive preoccupation
with orderliness, perfectionism, and mental and interpersonal
control.
Right.
But the kicker is that this control comes at the absolute
cost of flexibility, openness, and efficiency.
The cost is huge.
This person is extremely rigid.
They are intensely devoted to work and productivity to the
complete exclusion of leisure activities and friendships.
They literally cannot delegate tasks because no one else will
do it exactly right.
They hoard worn out or worthless objects, and they are
frequently described by others as incredibly stubborn.
It really paints a picture of a life that is highly
constricted.
Yeah.
Every single thing must be exactly in its place, both
physically and metaphorically.
The margins for error are just non-existent.
But see, people use the phrase, I'm so OCD, so casually
in everyday life.
Oh, constantly.
You hear it all the time.
Someone likes their desk clean and they say, oh, I'm
so OCD.
Someone color codes their bookshelf, I'm so OCD.
Based on this source text, we need to completely
dismantle that phrase.
Yes, please.
Because the notes make it abundantly clear that OCD
and OCPD are absolutely not the same thing.
They share three letters and they occasionally share
an outward aesthetic of neatness, but psychologically
they are entirely different animals.
And this is the big reveal of the notes.
This is the golden rule the exam is testing.
Okay, let's break down the mechanics of OCD first,
the one everyone thinks they know.
Right.
OCD, or obsessive compulsive disorder, is fundamentally
an anxiety disorder.
Okay.
A person with OCD experiences true obsessions.
These are intrusive, unwanted, horrific thoughts that
spontaneously enter their mind.
Wow.
And to relieve the agonizing anxiety caused by
those thoughts, they perform compulsions, which are
repetitive behaviors they feel forced to execute.
So like, think of a person who has an intrusive
thought that their family will die in a fire.
So their brain tells them they have to flick the
light switch exactly seven times before leaving
the room to prevent it.
Yes, exactly.
The crucial psychological term the text introduces
here for OCD is ego-dystonic.
Ego-dystonic, right.
So ego refers to the self and dystonic means in
conflict with.
Got it.
So if a condition is ego-dystonic, it means the thoughts
and behaviors are intensely unwanted.
They're distressing.
They're in direct conflict with who the person
actually wants to be.
So the person flicking the light switch seven
times knows it doesn't make logical sense.
They don't want to do it.
They are exhausted by it.
It feels like a hostile virus has basically hijacked
their brain.
Exactly.
They're essentially a hostage to their own
mind.
They're actively suffering and usually seeking
help to make it stop.
Right.
Now contrast that mechanical reality with
OCPD obsessive compulsive personality
decoder.
Okay.
What's the difference?
OCPD has no true obsessions and no true
compulsions.
None at all.
None.
There are no intrusive thoughts about fires
and no magical light switch flicking to
prevent them.
OCPD, it is a pervasive, deeply ingrained
perfectionistic personality style.
And crucially, it is ego-syntonic.
Ego-syntonic.
Okay.
So, synthetic meaning in harmony with the
self.
Yes.
If we connect this to the bigger picture of
how humans experience their own
consciousness, ego-syntonic means the person
actually believes their rigid, unyielding
way of living is simply the correct way
to exist.
Wow.
So they aren't tormented by intrusive
thoughts forcing them to be perfect.
They genuinely believe that extreme
perfectionism, stringent rule following,
and absolute order are moral imperatives.
Yes, exactly.
To build on the computer analogy from
earlier, if OCD is a virus that the user
hates and desperately wants to delete,
OCPD is the operating system itself.
That is such a good way to look at it.
And the user thinks it's the greatest,
most efficient operating system ever
designed, even as it constantly crashes and
alienates absolutely everyone around them.
Right.
OCPD, who color codes their closet,
refuses to let their spouse load the
dishwasher because they do it wrong and
works 80 hours a week, doesn't think they
have a medical problem.
They think the rest of the world is just
lazy, messy, and horribly incompetent.
That is a staggering shift in
perspective.
The person with OCD is in the doctor's
office pleading like, please help me stop
doing this.
Yes.
But the person with OCPD is dragged to
therapy by their frustrated spouse and
says, why would I change?
I'm the only one holding this family
together.
That's exactly why it is such a classic
diagnostic trap.
Yeah.
If a doctor only looks at the outward
behavior like a hyper focus on
cleanliness or order, they might quickly
scribble down OCD.
But the internal mechanical experience
is diametrically opposed.
We want to make sure you listening
really anchor this concept because the
source text practically highlights it in
neon yellow.
It really does.
The golden rule for the clinician
is this.
Unwanted and distressing is OCD.
What is entirely right to them is
OCPD.
The notes explicitly state that if you
grasp that fundamental difference in
internal experience, you pass the
question.
It requires the clinician to slow down
and ask the most important question,
which is, how does the patient actually
feel about their own behavior?
You can't just look at the
metaphorical x-ray.
You have to ask the patient what the
bone feels like.
Exactly.
Let's do a quick recap of the
psychological landscape we just
mapped out through these prep notes.
Sounds good.
We looked at three highly distinct
ways the human mind attempts to
manage profound fear and anxiety
in cluster C.
First, we explored avoidant
personality disorder.
This is the individual who desperately
desires human connection, but
is paralyzed by the anticipation of
shame and rejection.
We learned they are treated with
cognitive restructuring and gradual
exposure, and clinicians must
carefully differentiate them from the
schizoid personality who genuinely
lacks the desire for connection in
the first place.
Yeah. And then we transitioned to
dependent personality disorder
where the fear of separation drives
an overwhelming need to be cared
for, resulting in an outsourcing
of adulthood through submissive and
clinging behavior.
Yep.
The therapeutic goal there is
painstakingly building autonomy
and the major trap is confusing
their inward, clinging submission
with the explosive, unstable
reaction of a borderline
personality facing that exact
same fear of abandonment.
Finally, we tackled the ultimate
diagnostic trap, OCPD
versus OCD.
We unpacked the profound difference
between the egotistonic suffering
of true obsessions and compulsions
and the egosyntonic reality of
OCPD, where a rigid need
for perfectionism and control feels
perfectly right and justified to
the person living it.
It's a remarkable tour through the
architecture of human coping
mechanisms.
And honestly, this raises an
important question, one that
extends far beyond the scope of
passing a medical exam.
Ooh, what are you thinking?
Well, we spent a significant
amount of time unpacking that
egosyntonic versus
egotistonic concept, right?
Yeah, we did.
If a personality structure like
OCPD feels entirely right
and correct to the person
experiencing it.
I mean, if their internal voice
is in total unquestioning
harmony with their outward
actions, how do we actually
define the line between
a personality quirk and
a clinical condition that
requires medical treatment?
Oh, wow.
That is a fascinating
philosophical puzzle.
Right. If the patient feels
perfectly fine and doesn't
believe they are broken, who
gets to decide that they are?
It challenges us to consider how
much of our definition of a
disorder is based simply on
whether our internal monologue
agrees with what we're doing
versus how much friction and
pain our behavior causes to the
people forced to live alongside
us. That is a phenomenal
thought to leave you with today
because going back to our x-ray
machine from the very
beginning, oh, wait, I shouldn't
say dot, dot, dot going back to
our x-ray machine from the
very beginning.
If the bone looks completely
bent on the screen, but
the patient insists it
functions perfectly and doesn't
hurt them at all, is it really
broken? Exactly.
The murky, endlessly complex
waters of the human mind,
everyone. Thank you so much for
joining us on this deep dive
into cluster C.
Keep learning, keep questioning
those assumptions and stay
curious.